in a small sleepy oregon town jacob
pierce was turning 10 years old his
friends and family had gathered for a
birthday party in their local park it
had all the makings of a perfect day for
a young boy entering the double digits
for the first time there was a hired
magician attempting to make balloon
animals as children loudly mocked him
there was cake ice cream and an ice
cream cake for those who couldn't make
up their mind about which they'd rather
have there were pizzas pepperoni and
cheese and bowl after bowl of chips
jacob was having the best day ever as he
blew out the candles on his birthday
cake he quietly wished for something
amazing to happen it was already a good
day but it was also a little mundane a
fan of science fiction and fantasy jacob
had always quietly hoped that turning 10
would usher in an era of magic and
mystery perhaps he would encounter
aliens for the first time maybe he would
solve a grand mystery or learn about a
civilization of tiny people living in
his backyard or maybe
just maybe he would wake up to find he
had acquired magical powers suddenly he
would cease to be an ordinary young boy
who had to worry about math homework and
playground bullies he would instead
become something special someone who
could change the world around him and
finally make a difference just like the
heroes of all of his favorite books so
as his mother set the cake down in front
of him and everyone sang happy birthday
with loud off-key enthusiasm jacob
closed his eyes and wished little did he
know that his wish was about to come
true at least it sort of was after cake
it was time for every kid's favorite
part of their birthday party the
presents a stack of colorfully wrapped
packages sat on the picnic table just
waiting to be unwrapped jacob bounced
excitedly waiting for his mother to give
the all clear she gathered all the kids
and jacob's 19 year old brother nathan
and instructed them to sit down and
watch jacob open his gifts he tore the
paper from board games action figures
and an ill-advised stuffed animal or two
when suddenly nathan produced a package
he hadn't seen before it was a lumpy
item wrapped in green paper he handed it
to jacob who thrilled to be receiving a
special present from his beloved older
brother immediately opened it there was
a toy dart gun already loaded with a
large foam dart overcome with excitement
jacob jumped up from his seat and asked
if he could play with it now his mother
said it was fine and jacob and his
friends immediately jumped into action
they ran across the park as jacob aimed
the dart gun and decided which target to
fire at it as he squeezed the trigger
aiming for his best friend trevor nathan
called out to him don't shoot at him he
yelled with sudden urgency startled
jacob moved at the last minute and the
dart fired at a nearby stone wall
instead of its original nine-year-old
target as soon as the dart hit the wall
it transformed into a wobbly stack of
large stones the stones tumbled down
landing on several people standing
nearby a man who had been leaning on the
wall fell to the ground where his leg
was crushed under a falling stone the
magician who was packing up his supplies
took a rock to the head and was
immediately knocked unconscious the park
broke into pandemonium people running
and screaming trying to figure out how a
previously solid wall had turned into
falling rocks nathan scooped up jacob
the gun and the dart and pulled him away
from the chaos someone called the police
where an embedded scp foundation
operative was alerted to the situation
unfolding before jacob and his family
could vacate the park two scp operatives
were already arriving on the scene after
speaking with several eyewitnesses they
identified the source of the anomalous
activity as the toy gun and seized it
for further investigation all witnesses
including jacob and his mother were
given amnestics in order to erase their
memory of the toy gun and the incident
in the park nathan pierce who was
considered a person of interest for his
initial possession of the gun could not
be found he fled detention and
foundation custody further indicating
his knowledge of the gun's anomalous
properties and possibly indicating he
was responsible for its creation his
online activity linked him to an
organization satirically called gamers
against weed a group of interests that
had previously been linked to other
anomalies seized by the foundation his
younger brother jacob had without any
knowledge received a birthday gift that
would later become designated
scp-3108
scp-3108 is a modified nerf brand dart
gun that when paired with its foam dart
ammunition designated scp-3108-1
demonstrates anomalous transformative
properties when it fires other nerf
darts it behaves like any ordinary toy
and the same goes for the dart when
fired from any other nerf gun the only
notable difference between scp-3108
and any other ordinary toy dart gun is
the writing on the side which reads op
please nerf in red ink when
scp-3108 is fired at an object it will
immediately be transformed or altered in
a way that turns it into a worse version
of itself this can range anywhere from
small changes to complete transformation
on a molecular scale the law of
conservation of mass does not apply to
these changes and the gun's effects
appear to defy the laws of physics the
transformed objects are not themselves
anomalous in any way and the changes
they undergo appear to be influenced not
by objective reality but by the opinion
of whoever wields the gun whatever the
person firing
scp-3108 thinks would make the target
worse is what comes to pass an external
examination of scp-3108 revealed that it
is made of a steel outer shell with
decorative bronze inlays it can be
physically damaged but resists any
attempts to take it apart security
officer silva attempted to take it apart
with his hands during a round of tests
but before he could break open the shell
he found his hands had transformed into
a pair of rubber gloves they hung limp
and useless from his wrists as he
flopped them around yelling for
assistance officer silva was promptly
placed on leave and no more attempts to
disassemble
scp-3108 has been made since aside from
this one instance
scp-3108 does not have any effect on
objects that are not directly hit by its
star a variety of tests were performed
headed by dr johnson and dr dietz in
order to further examine the anomalous
properties of scp-3108
first a traditional dartboard made of
sissil fibers was set up on the wall of
the lab when hit with
scp-3108 the dartboard changed to a cork
board of the same shape and size filled
with several small holes and bearing a
noticeable beer stain a piece of 8x11
printer paper was transformed into a
square of single ply toilet paper a
sturdy coffee mug from the on-site
cafeteria changed into a small tea cup
made of the same kind of ceramic a
dollar changed into a fake 100 bill from
the board game monopoly it was
determined that the gun's effects are
determined by the personal preference of
the person firing it when it was fired
at a can of coke they can immediately
turned into a can of pepsi much to the
dismay of security officer mike who was
observing the experiment and who
preferred pepsi he took the gun next and
fired it at the can which promptly
turned back into coke on another day of
trials a vhs tape of the 1971 film willy
wonka and the chocolate factory was
transformed into a dvd copy of the 2005
remake of the same film prompting the
research team to wonder does the gun
have a sense of humor it seems so next
the research team began conducting
trials on living organisms a rat was
transformed into an ant which dr dietz
found confusing a female golden
retriever was turned into a female
american shorthair cat unusually large
at a weight of 15.4 kilograms and
displaying behavior more consistent with
that of a dog after rats and dogs the
team decided to move forward into human
trials a 28 year old male was hit with
the gun and promptly turned into a
living specimen of homo neanderthalensis
right before the research team's eyes he
regressed into a real live neanderthal
after this trial the team decided to see
how dangerous the gun could be if pushed
to the limits security officer gardner
was handed
scp-3108 and ordered to fire the gun
repeatedly reloading each time until
told to stop a 24 year old man was
instructed to stand in the firing range
and remain still first he transformed
into a prehistoric man then an
unidentified species of given and next a
three-toed sloth on nine occasions of
the gun being fired the subject did not
change species but rather took on
physical signs of injury or disease
after 46 shots testing was finally
stopped after the subject was reduced to
a small variety of earthworm after
attempting to track him down
unsuccessfully for months nathan pierce
was finally located by foundation
personnel and apprehended at an internet
cafe in los angeles california he was
taken into custody and brought to site
64 for questioning about the creation of
scp-3108
dr deeds conducted the interview and
asked why nathan created the gun nathan
referred to it as the nerfing gun and
explained that he thought it would be
funny it didn't have any particularly
grand purpose or intention it was just
something he had come up with and
thought it would be entertaining he
experimented with it for a while got
bored of it and then gave it to his
brother as a gift his only regret was
not giving his brother a proper warning
on how to use it before doing so dr
dietz applied a little pressure
insisting that the anomaly was dangerous
and could turn people into invertebrates
this stopped the interview cold as
nathan became visibly distressed he
insisted that it was never intended to
be used on people but for low-level
mischief he concluded the interview by
saying why would you turn a joke into a
torture device and demanded that dr
dietz leave his cell and stop speaking
to him nathan pierce was later released
from custody and the containment
procedures for
scp-3108 were updated with this new
information in mind
scp-3108 is contained in the standard
anomalous containment vault in site-64
and is not allowed to be removed from
said vault except for use in experiments
proposed testing must be approved by dr
johnson and dr deeds before it can be
conducted the gun may not be stored
while loaded and the foam dart is stored
in a separate containment vault during
any and all testing
scp-3108 is only to be handled by
security staff only one officer may hold
and fire the object at a time while a
secondary officer observes and watches
for potential accidents or any
unapproved use of the item researchers
and d-class personnel are not permitted
to fire the gun due to concerns about
safety and security it may not be used
under any circumstances in cross testing
with other scp objects it is also
forbidden from use in any testing on
humanoids as this is now considered an
ethics violation how would you use the
nerfing gun if it ever fell into your
hands and what do you think would happen
let us know down in the comments or
we'll shoot and make your comments
terrible now go check out irresistible
pickup artist
scp-3512 the more you know and top 8 scp
objects you actually want for more dark
and often hilarious anomalies